you
[Music]
all right good morning everyone thank
you for coming I'd like to thank data
Council and Pete for allowing me to
speak here so my name is Nick Shrock I'm
the founder of a company called
elemental but what I'm gonna be talking
about today is our first project and
it's an open source project called
daxter and there's the first time we've
been able to talk about it in public so
it's a super exciting day for us so just
a little about me I want to step back
and talk about why I'm here so I spent
the bulk of my career at Facebook and I
should worked at Facebook working on
frameworks for our product developers so
externally I'm best known as the
co-creator of graph QL I won't be
talking about graphical today but it's
kind of what I'm known for and you know
it's really been an honor to watch that
become an open-source technology that's
really broadly adopted and its really
kind of I think demonstrated the power
of not just technological transformation
but using technology to change the
dynamics within an organization so I
left Facebook in February 2017 and I
started going around talking to
companies about what their problems are
technically and I was talking to people
both inside the valley and outside the
valley this kept on they kept on saying
this over and over again our data is
totally broken and I found that very
confusing so I'm like I don't even know
what that means
like what do you actually mean by that
when you dig into it you start hearing
phrases like we don't know where the
data comes from we have no idea what it
means we have no idea how to reliably
process it we don't know how to test it
our engineers don't even wanna touch
this stuff and it's not fun it's not
sexy and my confusion got deeper because
I had been told by reliable sources that
data science is the sexiest job of the
21st century so then the next step is to
go talk to data scientists and so what
did dad what did your data scientists
what do you actually do day to day and
the answer is
variably something like this I just
convert Jason Python dictionaries of
back and so this is an interesting
journey to explore and a more common
formulation is something like this you
hear this that almost every talk you
ever go to which is I spend 20% of my
time doing my job and 80% of my time
doing it a cleaning now I found this to
be a curious formulation because the
implication is that everything which is
not their job is data cleaning which is
very strange and so I think this was
actually one of the cases where people
were saying one thing because of the
pain they're experiencing but they're
actually diagnosing a far deeper problem
so when people talk about data cleaning
they're talking about all sorts of stuff
right they're talking about rolling
their own infrastructure right common
workflow for a data scientist in today's
world is you give them a CSV file and a
jupiter notebook and you're like do
stuff that is crazy
that's actually everyone's used to it
but it actually is insane that that's
what we do data scientists realize
instinctively that a lot of the work
they do is repeated meaning like in kind
of an ecosystem way like they're doing
work that someone else probably should
have done and then at the end of the day
they often have to maintain these
unreliable processes that they haven't
tested and they don't really know how
productionize and I think when people
say data cleaning they basically mean
all sorts of activities like this then
you go and talk to a business leader
right all right so date is broken tell
me what that means
and they say something like this our
beta projects fail all time all right
it failure is the norm which is also
kind of crazy so summarize the state of
things
you got engineers saying I don't touch
this stuff you got data scientists and
they tell me they're wasting all their
time and then the leaders saying that
what it just it never works this is
where we are this is kind of the state
of things the people in this room are
kind of at the
upper upper echelon of Technology here
right a lot of people here a bill DeJohn
accustomed infrastructure so they
succeed more than the norm but this is
kind of the state of everything and so
as I was kind of taking stock of this
landscape this actually reminded me
something you have to bear with me here
it actually reminded me of conversations
I had 10 years ago with people writing
you eyes so if you talked to someone in
2009 they would likely say something
like this
I spend 80 percent of my time fighting
the browser and 20% of my time building
my app now if you were around in 2009
and within screaming distance of a UI
engineer you'd start hearing pained
yelling that their screens about ie6
right this is what they were dealing
with but it was interesting well
skipping here so you would hear things
like this all right we can't change our
uy we can't test it breaks all the time
right all right shooters don't want to
touch it and when they do all they do is
a hop into the codebase make something
fly around the screen then get the hell
out and that breaks a week later right
that was the state of things fast
forward to today front-end engineering
is incredible now you might you might
get a different impression from some of
the chatter on Twitter but in the
reality of things it is a very healthy
ecosystem like working in a full modern
JavaScript stack is a magical experience
and yes the browser's did get better but
I would argue that it wasn't decisive it
was the software abstractions that were
built on top of the browsers that truly
transformed the trajectory and totally
changed its trajectory of this ecosystem
so systems like angular systems like
View j/s and then systems like react
right react react was kind of V in my
I'm probably biased but it was V I think
decisive abstraction that changed the
course this whole ecosystem both angular
and view now essentially defined
themselves in opposition or in response
to react and so
what was what what made react so good
and one thing about it is that react
acknowledged the complexity of the
problem they were solving you weren't
just scripting a webpage you were
building a full application with all the
complexity they're in and react provided
abstractions and formalisms that matched
that complexity and then beyond
technology react respected the
discipline so front end before react in
the late 2000s was kind of this software
engineering backwater and there's often
kind of a lack of respect and almost
kind of a self deprecation in that field
and that is no longer true anymore the
systems that are built in front end or
real lots of engineers like to engage in
that ecosystem it is truly a world
transformed so reacted us into this
world of building these fully fledged
well abstract to front up applications
and I would argue that we're on the cusp
of a new era in data right we're
building we're not just building a bunch
of disconnected scripts that are
stitched together with a workflow engine
right these are full applications
they're they're alive they're
extraordinarily complex built with a
huge heterogeneous array of tools built
by a bunch of different personas they
are incredibly complicated and I would
argue that they're they're the
abstractions and systems that are
operating the ecosystems today don't
live up to the underlying complexity
that we're actually dealing with and so
what we're what Dexter is trying to do
is being part of this journey of kind of
moving this domain forward from not just
a bunch of disconnected pipelines but
instead to be building full data
applications so some core principles
here so at Facebook I started a team
called product infrastructure which
ended up creating react I didn't work on
react but I was you know within shouting
distance of them and I worked on graph
QL but we had kind of these timeless
principles that I think really apply to
what we're building here in the data
domain so one is that this kind of goes
without saying is that you're solving a
real problem
I'm gonna get it we're gonna talk about
the rest of the time see if I can prove
to you that we are solving a real
problem here but in terms of process
there's just a few things I think are
utterly critical one is an incremental
adoption path so very typically in the
data domain people want to provide these
fully vertically integrated stacks that
replace a whole bunch of things at the
same time it's not a realistic approach
may be able to pick off things one
system one task at a time you want to
preserve the tools that work you have
made huge investments notebooks spark
data warehouses air flow etc etc you're
not gonna be asked to abandon those
overnight and then immediate value value
in productivity gates so yes there's a
long term vision we're like there's
gonna be some glorious end state with
data applications that work perfectly
but in the short term you have to
install this thing get immediate value
all right so these are kind of core
principles so I've been talking for a
long time you're probably actually
wondering what what are you what are you
actually talking about what are you
doing looking to get to code very very
soon here but we're building data
applications how would I define that
so everyone uses old terminology they
like separate ETL and ml into two
different boxes I found that very
confusing because if you look at a ml
engineer and the ETL engineer they are
doing the same thing just at the end of
a supervised learning process there's a
model and a ETL there's like a data
Harris table or file but regardless of
what they doing they're doing this you
are building a graph of functions that
ingest and produce data assets that is
the core problem that's trying to solve
so that is the core abstraction on which
daxter is built so without further ado
let's pip install this thing and see
what the hell I'm talking about
so you open up a code editor and we're
going to do hello world here so we
import a pipeline and a solid so a
pipeline is just a dag of what we call
solids and the solid you can approximate
is just a unit of functional computation
fancy word for function
in this case we're just gonna log hello
world into this context object that we
flow throughout the computation and once
you kind of structure your code like
this you immediately get to lean out of
the box so we're gonna launch this tool
that we called agate all right so we
open up we have this web tool boom you
can view a pipeline right here is a
beautiful UI really nice the team has
done amazing work here and so you can
start your execution here we'll go
through all this slower later but in the
end there it is classic computer science
blinking light demo okay so Daggett
serves is this kind of like development
environment I think one of the things we
can do in order to provide a ton of
value is dramatically improve the local
development experience right right now
the norm is to develop in production
kind of sane and so and as we go through
this we're gonna kind of hop back and
talk about what we've introduced here so
we've introduced the notion of a
pipeline which is a directed acyclic
graph of solids and then a solid which
is a unit of functional computation all
right
well hello world is cute blurs actually
adapt a real example with real living
breathing code into the system so we're
gonna take the public example of running
running PageRank on pi spark then
adapted into our system so here's this
existing code it's a command-line
utility takes a file path and a number
of iterations it calls a function with
those arguments but now we're going to
do some stuff up here so we initialize
the spark context we load in a file we
do some compute on it we actually do the
PageRank algorithm and then we go
through and we print out the results of
this right pretty straightforward pice
bar code have you ever dealt with it now
we're gonna do is do the best code or
use strategy of all time which is copy
and paste it in here and then we're
gonna make this a daxter pipeline so
we're gonna add a few concepts up here
so that we can actually do what we want
to do gonna kill the old solid and then
we're gonna make this existing with this
existing function we brought in we're
gonna make this thing a solid so it's
just a plain old Python function
we annotate it and we make it a
so-called solid now we mark with
metadata and inputs so we have an input
which is a file path ok and then we also
have a notion of configuration so input
is equivalent to data whereas
configuration more configures how
something is comp computed very
concretely inputs can come from previous
computations than the tag you'll see why
we did that in a second
so we add our context object and instead
of getting interations that argument
we're going to get its configuration and
then we hop down here instead of
printing it out we're gonna log it to
that context object that we provide and
that's it we've adapted PageRank to our
system pop in here
load it up you'll notice that all the
meta information that we've encoded in
the program is surfaced here so there's
a path right here there's a
configuration down here and as a result
of providing those things boom now we
have this auto completing type-ahead and
you'll see as we type ahead we get live
errors about what's going on right no
more searching through random Jason
config files that God knows what they do
when they break right you have a very
well-structured config system that
automatically schematize is high quality
errors etc right you log this we can
filter down to debug
yeah and we're printing out stuff to the
screen ok this looking pretty cool it's
going the next thing so right I'm
getting too far ahead of myself here so
solids have inputs they also have
outputs it's probably a little bit of a
mission on this screen and they also
have configuration ok what's next well
what we're gonna do you're not supposed
to read this but effectively what we're
going to do is take this one function
and break it into two functions okay so
we're going to separate it into loading
the data and execute it so we have these
two functions to neuters here and what
we have to do now to make this a career
and pipeline is connect them together
with a dependency okay so what we're
gonna do here is add a thing to our
pipeline definition hmm there we go
you notice its dependencies dictionary
down here now if you're familiar with
the system like air flow air flow just
has a dependency graph between tasks or
as this is a dependencies between the
way the data flows into the system so if
you notice here our dependency graph
says like hey I have this input
it's called links I want you to get it
from the output of that previous
computation right and stitch that
together and so that actually gives us a
lot of power if we go back here now we
zoom in to this and we see that the
inputs and outputs are connected right
go here and execute it our config files
actually divide it sorry those too fast
and now we're gonna show that so we can
actually eat this thing when we complete
that execution but then we can actually
go back and select a subset of the deck
so we have this solid sub selection
thing we're gonna be like hey I only
want execute part of this graph now the
configuration schema is dynamic based on
what you selected and now we can execute
and we just excuse one piece of this
thing all right so now we have
dependencies we're able to stitch these
solids together into a dependency graph
of compute so what's next
so you notice in the code that we nude
up a spark session directly and what we
think is a really really important
concept is to separate your business
logic from your environmental concerns
and that means what we want to do is
have the system manage a spark session
for you okay it makes it code more
testable it also has some other nice
benefits as well the way we're gonna do
that and you notice that instead of
directly accessing the spark session we
actually hang it off our contacts down
there okay so there's also ecosystem of
libraries so from the daxter PI spark
library which we also released today you
can import a spark session resource and
the details here don't matter but the
key thing is that we're configuring it
so that hey there's a resource and it's
called spark and it's a spark session
resource all right now how many of you
have written a spark job
interact with spark at all all right how
many of you have struggled with
configuring spark right that's a hundred
percent hit rate well that this combined
with the config editor if you don't like
this I I don't understand how your mind
works so we can scope this out right
we've added some type information now
there's this config schema down here
right and so what we've done is we've
imported the entire spark configuration
schema right we're gonna we have to
click down to this thing boom boom boom
boom boom and then awesome bam right the
entire spark config schema with imbedded
documentation all right there right you
can mouse over it stuff happens you all
see there's an error at the same time oh
that's an you know it's a number we
expected a string and on and on and on
right this is a highly generic
configurating system of which spark is
one example target right it's a very
pluggable system you can add your own
config schema now we're executing this
thing look there's fubar right there we
configured it properly okay so now the
other thing this enables is the ability
to re execute specific parts of our
pipeline we're actually going to
configure this to automatically persist
the intermediate materializations of
this pipeline and we're gonna inject an
error
so what we're simulating here is like
you're only a pipeline it's been running
for a while then the last task fails
you're like oh god now after we've run
this entire thing it's a nightmare
so we just reran this thing it's gonna
pop up an error we have this nice render
in so you can go get your stack trace go
to what line of code you're dealing with
now look at this we can just we execute
this single thing right we think this
capability is just a massive leap
forward for local development in our
super practical way this is a super
practical problem that every data domain
person interacts with so there we fix
the problem
we re execute just that thing and
[Music]
executing we have it's green again right
super-powerful tooling so we've added
these concepts and this is not the meant
to be kind of there's a lot of stuff to
absorb so you know and this is the goal
of this is not for you to be able to
look at this thing and immediately go
and start developing on it but we're
giving you a sense of how these
abstractions interleave in order to
provide real value to our users okay so
just to sum up oh wait wait wait that
out of order here so one I think one
really useful way to evaluate these new
technologies is to orient it to other
existing technologies where does this
fit into the ecosystem so we have our
centralized abstraction called daxter we
have a Python implementation of it a
Python library that you pip install and
we've demonstrated how we have
integrations with price mark underneath
it by adopting the abstraction you get
these beautiful high quality tools right
it's kind of a suite of tools called
daggit but they're pretty independent we
have the catheter the dag viewer our
execution console the way we've written
this if we've written it over an API and
the API is really what this system has
is in its core so what does this API do
well as they described before we
describe a data application is a graph
of functional compute and what does that
allow you to do we can query those graph
of functions we can introspect on them
figure out what the shape of it is we
can actually over this API operate them
meaning that we can both configure and
execute those computations and then also
over that API we can monitor them right
so we we have this live subscription
service this stuff happens to be
implemented on graph QL for obvious
reasons but it's not it's not you know
directly linked to the system it's
actually it's an incidental fact about
it but it's these core capabilities that
are the most important thing and so Dex
there's not just a set of tools because
it's an open API using an open standard
if you adopt this thing you can also
build your own internal tools on the sub
traction so this ends up being a
platform for tool building go back here
and now all right spark developers here
how many people use PI spark primarily
and how many people use Scala spark
javis burg okay so this is for you
is that okay pi sparks cute and I'm a
real spark developer nice I use Scala
this is this pythons joke well just so
happens we can also script Python you
know spark computations written in Scala
and then we can also you know by the
word functional compute is chosen very
carefully mean like a coarse-grained
function ie a spark job a database you
know a sequel query that say creates a
table or some of the artifact so let's
demonstrate that so we have out of the
box these spark solids and snowflake
solids just as examples they're not kind
of ready to go industrial-strength it's
more for the demo but it shows the
promise of the system so now we have a
pipeline that is more realistic and
ingest events so we download a file from
s3 it unzips that file you know look at
all this embedded documentation and then
what it does is actually ingest that
event produces park' files using spark
and we have these things called asset
tags where we can actually embed meta
information be like hey this is the this
is the java class actually does this we
also have a auto complete auto
completing a syntax highlight sequel
editor right so you can kind of get full
context in your pipeline so now we
execute this thing so this is actually
doing a spark submit as you can see in
the middle there and this is actually
executing a database load and because
this is all built on that same API layer
right even though it's multilingual we
can use the same features that we had
before we just re executed the snowflake
load independently and imagine you had
done something dumb and mistyped the
sequel query and it's equals dynamic so
you can't check it ahead of time and so
boom we've integrated that
so just to take a beat here for a second
we've demonstrated how this is an
open-source Python library it is
available right now we've actually been
developing out this out in the open the
whole time it has these multilingual
integrations and this out-of-the-box
beautiful tooling but just to go back to
what we were talking about the beginning
what about those data scientists you
really address that yet and you know
what is the problem happening in data
science they're what you know what
problem are we think is most important
well essentially it's this is that the
current status quo in most organizations
is that data science and engineering
there's two sealed siloed world the data
scientists do some work over here they
present their model throw it over the
proverbial wall up to the engineers to
implement productionize it the engineers
don't understand the model the data
science known as the data science folks
don't understand the production
foundation issues it's a pretty
pathological situation actually only
just a bunch of negative organizational
dynamics where you want to get to is
here where they the disciplines are
respected and there's aspects of them
that overlap but they also do their own
individual activities that overlap is
cultural but it's driven by underlying
changes in tooling so I don't think you
talked about the chasm between data
science and engineering without talking
about Jupiter right Jupiter is the de
facto environment in which data
scientists do their work and there's two
schools of thought about Jupiter there's
this one I don't like them it's actually
a great talk it's very entertaining I
used to be in this camp and it for the
predictable reasons that a grumpy
engineer it's like oh it's not
reproducible I'm not storing things in
files I can't test this it's just insane
out of order execution model that's
hyper stateful like you people are all
your minds but then you see the way
people use them it's clearly valuable so
I was trying to grapple with this and
then actually Matt who's over there and
his team wrote this blog post which I
thought was extraordinary
and if you saw his talk yesterday he
gave a great summary of the technology
and it's called paper mill simply put it
allows you to execute a notebook as a
function and then I saw this and I'm
like well golly gee I'm you know working
on a framework where the fundamental
unit thing I'm building is a
coarse-grained function of functional
computation so like let's make one of
these paper notebooks paper mill
notebooks a solid so we're gonna we're
gonna extend the example pipeline we had
that ended with the sequel statement
we're actually gonna do a computation to
take that table and make it a data frame
and then we're gonna pass it to a
notebook all right so this is a notebook
solid and you can write in line and
daggit see what's going on right see
this computation that your data science
persons crafted but how do you actually
integrate that in the pipeline what does
that mean and this is where a paper mill
kick kicks in so if you check out this
notebook looks like a normal notebook
you can do all your insane out of order
execution to your heart's content all
right so we just injected an error we
fix it we recompute it you have to keep
track of the order of operations here
but this is what the paper magic though
there's a parameter self and we can
essentially say it's like hey at runtime
what we want to do is instead of
executing this notebook we're gonna
remove that cell and inject a new cell
with the production data that's how that
works so we're gonna go ahead and do
that so use the same tools and I was
gonna execute the thing blah blah blah
blah loading it's a snowflake just did a
spark job of some computation to produce
a data frame and now we're executing a
notebook and then you'll see this thing
it produced an output notebook so what
the output notebook is is it copy/paste
job of the original notebook but with
the production data in it and we just
clicked on it copied the location where
that output note was generated output
notebook was generated and now we can
view this and you in your tool of choice
right so here we're gonna open it up in
a notebook and so this is actually an
output of
the pipeline and it serves as a rich log
of computation so all of the charting
and graphing that your data scientists
have done can actually be used in
production logging and it also serves as
the debugging environment so whether or
not Dexter succeeds or not I think that
paper mill if it you know grows like I
think it should should revolutionize the
way that data scientists do their work I
think it's an extraordinary fans and we
want to integrate with those
technologies so we add another family of
tech underneath within the Dexter family
so let's dig into what's going on here
so what's interesting about this and if
you're at Julian's talk just before me
he set this up perfectly where actually
we have many many different personas
interacting with our pipelines that we
have data engineers analysts data
science base scientists etc
collaborating to build a single graph
functional compute a data application
those computations are accessible behind
an API and that's how we built these
first party tools and then when we come
out of the box with a very simple local
executor right so we can execute these
things on our machine now you might be
thinking yeah this looks cute a lot of
fancy-pants hipstery web tools I'm
interested in using this but I have my
existing stuff I have an airflow cluster
how the hell am I going to use this new
thing with that well turns out that what
we can do since its kind of structured
on top of an API is that we can query
that graph of computations and then
dynamically synthesize an airflow dag
right so you can encode your DAGs daxter
space and then effectively view airflow
is sort of a compilation target so what
does that look like that's it we import
our pipeline we point it to the
configurations that power of this
pipeline and then we
all function which makes a dag that's it
we're done we just did it we also have
an option for automatically container I
think max just got all pumped up he's
mr. mr. data engineer 2012 through 15
and so now we put this in our dag
loading script air flow runs and we can
load in the webserver and along with all
the examples which everyone knows come
with come with the system boom there it
is there's our deck native in airflow so
we've demonstrated how we can go to this
kind of from this compelling local
development environment integrating all
these different tools then very easily
completing the story by making it very
straightforward to deploy this to air
flow so let's sum this back up here so
EDA engineering you know last year this
conference is called data ang comp and
you know we it's been rebranded to data
Council to include data scientists but I
think also part of the reason it was
rebranded is that eight engineering is
still an emerging discipline I would say
and you kind of see this because there's
title arbitrage happening where people
are data engineers but they're like no
no no no no I'm a machine learning
engineer even though you're doing the
same exact thing that you did last week
right so I think people are still kind
of figuring out how to define what data
engineering means and what its eventual
end States gonna be and it's at an
inflection point and our thesis is that
inflection point is that we're moving
from assembling scripts and cuz went off
way to more full-fledged applications
complicated they're alive hard to keep
up and running and so we're trying to
address this with kind of a you know
three-pronged attack I guess one is this
new what we like to think is an elegant
programming model and then you can
leverage those that programming model to
use
new beautiful two-lane that we think
really adds a lot especially the local
developer experience and then it's a
flexible and incremental approach right
we demonstrated how it's integrating
with all the tooling that you depend on
both in terms of how you're modeling
your compute whether it's sparking data
warehouse or a notebook and also being
able to deploy to your existing
infrastructure in a permissionless way
right you could actually synthesize an
airflow dag using the system you don't
even tell your ops team right it's kind
of this bottoms up adoption approach and
I just want to dig into the flexible
incremental bit for a second what does
that mean it means you can use your
tools means you can preserve your
existing investments in your code and it
means you can deploy your infrastructure
and it means you can adopt
instrumentally all right these are
critical critical qualities for any
successful technology but there's
obviously a ton of work to do you know
where we're at right now is that you
know we have one alpha user who's in the
audience today the ape gong you saw him
at the panel and his company
superconductive but there's obviously a
ton of work to do we have a small team
super talented team they're over there
max Nate and Alex and they've just done
you know extraordinary work on this
project we also have other members who
have who have been working on the team
Ben and Mikhail are responsible for that
UI which really is really really nice to
work with and then uma worked with us
has been working with us to actually
build the daxter mill system and she's
done extraordinary work too and then I
would like to thank Abe and
superconductive health for being our
alpha user and you know really rolling
with the punches here so next steps here
one this is you know open source today
you can download and try it out but what
we're really looking for is one we're
still building our founding team so
we're hiring if you're just did talk to
me but we're also looking for kind of
I've heard a few terms for this like
design partner founding customer but
essentially what we're looking for is
two to three teams that we can work with
deeply embedded with those teams to
assist them and building their
infrastructure using those tooling and
then yeah you can always reach me by
email and that's my twitter handle and a
handle on everything else and without 30
that's it I'm done thank you very much
awesome talk I guess I my first really
big question is well you refer in your
example to input text not immutable
right because that's a reference to an
outside resource file system somewhere
or even database queries not immutable
what is your plan for your redux to your
react Wow that's it that's an insider
baseball question so the I think the the
what we will do is yes the input
artifacts are not unbeatable but the
system is configured to be able to
effectively take over kind of
effectively a folder or a bucket in s3
and use that to persist all the
intermediate artifacts that you end up
computing so that you at you you end up
being able to configure the system this
immutable log of all the data that
you've operated it on right and you
could extend that by making it easy to
copy the data that comes in externally
into this like an inputs folder into
that so that then you can do that redux
trick where you can kind of like replay
what happened in a very deterministic
fashion I think as we go forward you
know there will be opportunities
especially if we stack this on top of
containerization to be able to do things
like hash the inputs and be like oh I've
seen this before and I've computed this
before with this container so you can do
like minimum viable recompute we have
the software formalisms in place to do
that but that was a great question and
follow-up question on the other side so
outputs like let's say you send email
notifications and things like that
obviously those are side effecting to
the outside world they're not rollback a
bowl and so what do you have a plan for
the equivalent of an Haskell IO monad -
well this is a hard one to answer
because after 15 years or however long
I'm in the industry I still have no idea
what a monad is but but I mean you know
our kind of approach here is not to be
overly restrictive with a programming
model being like there are no side
effects ever that's not realistic that's
not the way these systems work our
request is that the system's don't lie
meaning that you can yes you can declare
your outputs but we also have this
ability for the solids to kind of
indicate that we call them
materializations we could be like heya
by the way I emitted this thing you know
that's exactly actually how that output
notebook works the the nope the solid
emitted the fact that like hey I produce
this materialization that's over here
like render that and your UI at a
minimum but later is a built the system
we'll be able to build formalisms to
capture that but we can't solve
idempotence for you you know like if you
email if in the middle you're you know
it's a Python program or whatever
program if you decide to email someone I
mean he mail went ow we can't you know
we can't fix that so there are side
effects in the world we will try to
build abstractions will have
abstractions kind of bottle them but we
can't solve the issue
[Music]